we've heard a lot about the talent of  this young man Alex hunter he had a wide  choice of clubs to sign for today his  journey begins as he makes his premier  league debut ends in a kid coming out  the exit regenerate this bunch interest  in years I never expected anything like  this yeah ago Alex hunter on his debut  you're in the big league now you have to  raise your game you need representation  you call me Wow check this place out  just don't get too carried away can  disappear just like that life doesn't  always give you what you want doesn't  I'm ready  you'll get your opportunity hunter just  give me out there  all matters all back this season and now  walk these big kick  I want to stay and fight for my place I  won't let you down  Alex cutter and a thousand gold welcome  to the premier league this young man has  everything we're gonna make history  my name is Alex hunter you don't know me  but believe me you soon will play it  first on Xbox one with EA access